hey I'm back in this video we're gonna
talk about why people really don't stick
to and stay consistent with healthy
eating now this probably is not targeted
to you but you probably know people and
friends and family that just cannot
stick to a diet no matter what the diet
that I've been recommending the key to
in a minute fasting program is very easy
to stick to it as long as you get into
it and get through that first two weeks
and then it's really easy because the
cravings go away and you're not hungry
anymore but for most people they still
have a hard time staying consistent so
let's talk about why that is you know
why don't people learn from their
experience like like a diabetic for
example if you're a diabetic you have a
40 X x it's 40 times the risk factors of
getting glaucoma then if you didn't have
diabetes now just that data alone would
give you prediction um chances are
you're gonna get glaucoma okay but
people again like to keep consuming junk
food they don't change why it's very
strange and I think really the big
reason why people can't stick to it is
because they live in the moment
in the present and not enough in the
future they're not thinking consequences
they're not living enough in the future
they're just living for the now they
want that quick sensation that quick
pleasure instant gratification but
without really kind of confronting
what's gonna happen down the road now
one of the things that I did in my book
is in the back I put something called
conscious eating cards you can cut it
out but in your purse but in your wallet
and the purpose for this is to really
make you very aware of the consequences
of doing certain things so like if
you're gonna eat a doughnut for example
or some juice or some alcohol it's
recommended that you read these to just
remind yourself and start living in the
future and decide what's gonna happen if
I consume this and is it worth it and
that's that'll actually may distract you
now if you take a look at the top ways
people actually die cancer stroke heart
attack kidney disease Alzheimer's
diabetes complications with the common
thread the common thread with all of
these is high levels of insulin so I
think the awareness
of understanding the mechanism the
cause-and-effect relationship and also
start living more in the future you
could just make better decisions so the
next time you get tempted from eating
that doughnut before you make the
decision really weigh it out is the
temporary pleasure really worth the
future consequences thanks for watching
hey thank you so much for watching keep
spreading the word and share this video